(upbeat music)
♪ Let's go ♪
- Hi guys, it's Justine.
- Hi, it's Tom and this is Charley.
- We just recorded a podcast,
and so excited.
Thank you so much for being on it.
- Thanks Justine,
thanks for having Charley
and I on the show.
We're super excited.
We're getting ready to
take off into the wild,
in our new van.
Charley and I just got this new van.
And we're gonna go explore America,
and I'm gonna be
producing and broadcasting
my podcast from the van.
It's gonna be fun.
- I'm gonna put links in the description
if you guys will check out the podcast,
check out Tom's podcast
and his YouTube channel.
Like you're making YouTube videos now?
- Yeah, I love it.
I'm having a lot of fun
with the new technology,
loving all the new
cameras and the new gear
that's out there that
makes it a lot easier
to make really beautiful pictures.
- He just got an A7SIII
which is very exciting.
Charley, Charley Charley Charley.
Cool, let's check out the van.
- Come here, let me just put you on your,
little leash for now.
Well, I'm training
Charley not to run away.
Cause we're gonna be in very remote places
so I'm training him to kind of be on...
This is a longer leash right now
but so soon when we're hanging out the van
she's not gonna be able
to run off in the woods
and get lost.
- [Justine] You have a GPS collar on her?
- I have a GPS collar on
her, she's micro chipped.
The thing that's amazing about this van,
is its really, these really
cool guys from Arizona
they make it, they're called Boho.
Boho, that's the name of their company.
They were on Shark Tank.
- No way.
- This is a Ram ProMaster
Van and they take it
and they convert it into a camper.
- I this all custom then, you
told them what you wanted?
- They kind of have been doing this.
So, in a lot of ways I kind of like
let them take the lead
'cause they know what they're doing,
but I did make a few
adjustments to certain things
for my studio and stuff.
The thing that's exciting
is like the battery system,
I'm gonna be able to go out into...
There's solar panels on the roof
that are running my electrical system.
I'm gonna be able to go
in the middle of nowhere
and run my recording studio.
And I'm recording my album,
my comedy country rap album.
I call it Comedy Country
Rap, it's C.C.RAP,
Comedy country rap, I'll be doing that--
- I'm smiling, but you can't see it.
It's under there.
- It's gonna be fun.
Justine, you wanna see
my 25 gallon water tank?
- Yeah.
- Yeah it's nice, right?
- Yes, it is.
- That's it. That's mine.
So you're out in the middle of the desert,
your electrical system is
powering, pressurizing your water,
and you get the idea,
and I shower.
- [Justine] That's pretty impressive.
- Nice shower in the desert.
- [Justine] Have you done this kind of
extensive camping before?
- I've done a lot of outdoors type stuff
cause I'm Canadian, I consider
myself an outdoors person.
As a kid I'd go on a lot of
canoe trips very, in depth,
sort of deep into the
wilderness canoe trips.
My father made me go.
- [Justine] It happens.
- I wanted to skateboard
but he said no no, you're
not skateboarding all summer.
You're going on a canoe trip.
This is my grill, see.
- [Justine] Sounds like you're prepped.
- So there's certain things you need like
when you're camping.
Like everyone needs an
ax for example, right?
You need an ax
cause you gotta chop your own wood,
because you gotta make fire.
This is my grill so I
could be like cooking,
shovel here,
fishing rod.
Brand new, got it on Amazon.
In fact, I got the ax on Amazon too.
- [Justine] And you can
basically get anything lately.
- Pretty much.
Pretty much, I got the van on Amazon.
- What are you gonna do about food?
- So food, let's see
here, these are chairs,
these are nice little chairs.
- [Justine] That's good.
- You could kind of imagine
what a chair looks like,
- [Justine] That's nice.
- Folds out and you have
a nice little chair.
This is a table, this
whole table to cook on.
Bow saw for more wood chopping.
- [Justine] Oh wow!
How long have you been planning this?
- About three months.
Let's just see what's in this one, here.
Let me just check what's in it first.
Okay, that's safe. All right.
- Yeah, but you've got so much snacks.
- Yes, it's a lot of snacks.
Because you wanna bring a lot of like,
non perishable foods, right?
Coffee...
See below here though,
I got lots of fruits and
vegetables like corn pineapple.
Lots of Clif Bars, pepper...
I am being cautious about
the pandemic right now.
So I'm not gonna be going to restaurants,
I'm not gonna be going through
McDonald's drive throughs,
things like that.
I'm gonna go hunker down in the wilderness
and I'm just gonna be cooking my own food.
I got a fishing rod too
for some fresh fish, so it'll be good.
- So are you planning on fishing
and then eating the fish too?
- Yeah, I'll eat the fish yeah.
I grew up fishing in Canada.
So I'll cook the fish.
- Okay 'cause I mean I
feel like if I went fishing
I'd be like I don't know
what to do with this now.
- Oh you just...
Well, kind of don't wanna get into detail
- Yeah.
- The adventure of this is
also figuring it all out.
- Just feel like you're
gonna figure out a lot,
very quickly.
- When you're at a
campsite, you can plug in,
so you've got unlimited power, right.
So you just plug the whole
van in this is a 30 amp plug.
This will convert a 30 amp
into an actual regular wall plug so...
In theory, I could plug into
an extension cord right here
and charge my battery
up and we'd run all day.
- [Justine] And you said you can last,
what like five-six days on the battery?
- I'd probably go about six days.
What I think you'd think is cool, which--
- [Justine] I think this is all cool.
- So I have an app on my phone,
Victron is the solar company.
So I have a Victron app on my phone,
and I can go on there and
monitor my battery life.
This is my jet boil electric kettle.
It is a big battery drainer.
This is a bag that you fill with water
and you put your clothes in
and you soak and you shake it up
and it's your little
portable washing machine.
I have biodegradable soap, right?
- [Jenna] Is that the peppermint?
- Yeah.
- That's the kind I use.
- You like that?
- Yes its nice.
- I've actually never used it before.
- Dr. Bronner's?
- Yeah.
Face masks, very important.
- Face masks, gloves
for cooking on the fire.
You gotta have a good hiking backpack.
- [Justine] Do you think
you'll do much hiking?
- I think so, yeah, I think I will.
As you can see, it's my new backpack.
I don't know how to open it.
Who's the new guy, huh?
- Who wants a new bag pack.
- Expert survivalist.
He can't get in his damn backpack.
Bear spray.
- [Justine] Very important.
- A platypus water bladder.
- [Justine] Oh!
- So you stick that in your backpack.
- [Justine] Yeah those are great--
- As you can see, I've used it a lot.
I've been hiking for
years, I've used it a lot.
I've encountered many bears and drank,
and gone on many deep woods hikes,
over the years, as you can see.
- I'd definitely open
the bear spray for you.
- Before you ever have
to use the Bear Spray,
you can use your Bear Horn.
And I am frontiersman.
Down booties.
- [Justine] That's nice.
- These are really good thing
to wear when you're sleeping.
Are you down with my booties?
These are good.
You like that. Funny, is that funny?
I thought it was pretty good.
First aid kit.
- [Justine] Jenna was very concerned.
- [Jenna] Very concerned
- Yeah, I've got that.
I swear I probably pay for the doorknobs
on Jeff Bezos' guesthouse
More COVID masks
Dog water.
- Those are great.
- There you go, you like knives?
- [Justine] Yes!
- Its a Buck knife.
(indistinct)
- Wanna see it?
- I do.
I love knives.
- Careful its sharp.
Be careful.
- Okay.
- Its sharp. Don't cut yourself.
- [Justine] Oh this is so nice.
See that was my first question,
I was like do you have a knife.
And you do, this is great
Do you wanna see my knife.
- Sure, okay.
- [Man] Holy crap.
- [Tom] Damn that's like some ninja.
- [Man] I'm sorry, how did that happen?
- [Justine] Well you
have to be very careful
or you'll stab yourself.
- [Tom] Yeah, don't do that.
Whoa, look at that, damn.
Mine's just for like cooking and cutting.
The Life straw, got that.
- [Justine] I think what Peter's saying is
you have an open any of your stuff,
you haven't opened any of it.
- Oh yeah I know.
it's like I'm a real expert.
Drip coffee, you pour.
I'm ready to go.
City kid to camping expert,
just with an Amazon
account just like that.
This is a nice knife,
you like knives right.
- [Justine] I do.
- This is another nice knife,
Swiss army knife.
- You've got all sorts of knives in here.
- So, it's good to have.
That's good for like when
you're fishing and stuff.
Now that's cool.
- [Justine] So you're
thinking long term here.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- Yeah.
- With the new world we're living in
I think you gotta find ways
of getting out in the world.
That's true I should
say, this isn't just like
a one off thing I'm going to do, as a bit.
I'm gonna be out there on the
road for the next few years.
Come on, my YouTube
channel or my Instagram
to see where I am, I'll
be somewhere out there.
- I think it'll be exciting.
- Fish bait.
- Oh fish bait.
- That's some bait for trout, power bait.
- Do you think non
trout would be into that
or is it just specific to trout?
- Well its probably good for trout like
rainbow trout golden
trout yeah like there's...
Probably be more for trout, yeah.
Like there's a certain fish you...
If I was going for fishing
for largemouth bass,
I wouldn't use that.
- [Justine] Is there a
largemouth bass bait?
- That's more...
Yeah, well I probably use
like a worm and a spinner.
- We used to go fishing with
dad, you don't remember?
- I hated--
- Hook a little...
We would go out at night,
we'd be picking the worm.
You didn't do that.
- I know I didn't.
I just didn't like stabbing the worm.
- You don't need to use the worm
like you an use a rubber worm.
That bait has a little scent to it.
- [Justine] I don't but I
mean I'm just imagining...
- The fish are attracted to the scent
as much as they are to seeing it.
Can I unplug this here?
- Yeah I think I'm done
stealing you're power now.
This looks so cool.
- Yeah, this seat obviously
is turned around right now
but Charley will sit here facing forward,
and she's got this booster seat.
And it's a seatbelt harness.
- [Justine] Yeah, that's so cute.
- She'll be up high.
In the next day or so I'm converting this
into a recording studio.
I have a rack with all my audio gear.
I'll be able to access my audio gear here,
This are some cool Focal studio monitors.
- [Justine] So how are you gonna have
the whole studio set up?
- Gonna have a large
electronic keyboard right here.
MPC drum machine which
I'll either have here
or possibly sitting right there.
My computer, a couple of
microphones, and that's the studio.
- [Justine] Its gonna be really cool.
- The main components of the studio
are gonna be under there.
And the idea is to be in the wilderness
and just kind of be inspired by nature
and trying to be creative.
- I think you've got
a good space for that.
- Yeah, it's gonna be bumping in here,
We'll be bumping some
crazy C.C.Rap in here.
- Good thing you're gonna
be in the middle of nowhere.
- Yeah--
- So I'm sure if you're at a campground
your neighbors will probably be like,
"I'm sorry what are you doing?"
- Excited about it, just
the sort of absurdity of it.
Being all by myself in
the middle of nowhere
with this kind of electronics...
This is also kind of a nice thing
just to see just to imagine,
This is a nice fan so it
creates nice air circulation.
It's got, like, got a guitar here.
- [Justine] Is it comfy?
- It's totally, it's a
really comfortable mattress.
I'm like maybe just a little
too tall for it but...
I'm on an angle like this.
No actually, I can, I
can, I can fit there,
- Plus you're gonna have Charley as well.
So that's gonna be a
whole another adventure.
This is cool.
This is what me and Jenna
have wanted to do for so long.
- This is a potty as well.
Some oatmeal,
- [Justine] I mean I already
had some this morning
but like--
- You want some for...
- Yeah I'll take it for later
- Would you like some?
- [Jenna] No I'm okay, I
don't wanna take your snacks.
You know what i need...
I mean I'll take it.
- Yeah sure, you can take it
home for later or whatever.
- [Justine] Do you like Cream of Wheat.
- Yeah, it's okay.
I'm more of a porridge kinda oatmeal guy.
I mean its, its okay.
- Yeah its like, it's my favorite.
- Yeah its good, I mean I'm not...
(indistinct)
- I like oatmeal too.
I just really like Cream of Wheat.
- Yeah its fine.
I'm just more of a, this is more my thing.
- Yeah its fine, its cool.
- I'm of a Quaker Oats.
- He's a good guy.
- So everyone's just
like don't judge right
- I mean I'm not, I have no judgment.
Zero judgment.
- I don't judge.
- [Justine] You should tell
us what you named the van.
- Oh yeah that's right.
- And why?
There's a whole story behind it.
- Yeah, and literally a whole story.
It's an incredible novel
by the great John Steinbeck
"Travels with Charley:
In Search of America."
In that book he gets a camper van in 1960.
It's a real story. He really did it.
And he drove across the country
and reports on his findings in his van.
In that book his dog is named Charley,
so I named my dog Charley
after Charley and travels with Charley,
and his man is Rocinante,
and it's written in the
exact Spanish script,
so it's a little bit of an...
Well it's a full on Amish
it's not a little Amish
- [Justine] So you just recently read it?
- Yeah just read it recently, yeah.
I really kind of sort of helped
inspire a lot of the
vibe that I'm finding.
Rocinante. Yes, Charley is a good girl.
Charley's a good girl.
Your shoes, Charley.
Charley.
- [Justine] Charley.
All right, well I guess,
I guess this is it.
Yeah, I know, it's so great.
Thanks Justine, I appreciate
you guys coming by.
It's great being on the show and--
- [Justine] Thank you so much.
- This is gonna be good, I mean.
Appreciate the help
with the technical stuff
because you're an expert
in this field and...
I've got my new camera I'm excited about
but I might be calling you asking,
like what's a proxy.
- You fixed my proxy problem.
- I fixed your proxy problem.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- So now I would be calling
you about the proxy's.
- Yeah, I fixed Justine's proxy problem.
- I fixed other problems for you
but the proxy one you've solved.
- Yeah, I appreciate it
- But I'm here for all
of your tech assistance.
I'm so excited about your trip.
Guys make sure you go check out
everything that Tom is
doing, it's so incredible.
I mean, you basically revolutionize
everything that everyone is doing now.
So to see you going out
and just embracing this--
- I'm just older than everybody else.
- Well, you learn a lot.
- No, it's fun, it's
this is exciting time.
And I'm still enjoying all the new tech
that's coming out and so much easier
to do cool stuff now for everybody.
- Yeah.
- Just to be able to, everyone
has access to a camera now.
It's exciting time and wouldn't make sense
to not embrace that and enjoy it
and keep having fun with
tech, so thanks everybody.
- See you guys on the internet,
Bye
- Bye internet.
- See ya.
- Bye bye internet.
- Bye.
(soft music)